The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So my
name is Chris Walley.
So I'm an associate
professor of anthropology
here in the
anthropology program.
So I think we're just going to
start out doing introductions.
Mostly my work as
an anthropologist
is in other areas other than in
documentary film, although I've
been working on documentary
film off and on for a number
of years, along
with Chris Boebel.
And we've currently been working
on a documentary project called
Exit Zero, which is about
a community in Southeast
Chicago that used to be
a steel mill community,
and all the industry left.
And it's sort of looking at
the social transformation
of this region.
So actually, a little
later in the class,
we'll show a bit of
that and just talk a bit
about the process of
making that film for us,
and some of the issues
that have been coming up
in the process of making it.
But anyway, so Chris, you
want to introduce yourself?
CHRIS BOEBEL: I'm Chris Boebel.
I'm a filmmaker.
I have a pretty varied
background in documentary film,
but also fiction film,
mostly independent film.
Some television, a lot
of commercial work.
I currently work at MIT doing a
lot of science documentary work
and instructing in this class.
And no science background.
I went to NYU Film School.
But I've done, both before
being at MIT and obviously
since, I've done a fair
amount of documentary focused
on issues that deal
in one way or another
with technology, nuclear power,
space travel, things like that.
And this is the man
behind the camera.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: I
think you should turn
the camera on yourself, Dave.
There you go.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Dave Stripinis
is our teaching assistant
who will be spending a
lot of time with you,
both on technical
and creative issues.
Really terrific editor
and cameraperson,
and all-round guru and
confidant and mentor.
Both Dave and I will
keep regular office hours
as the semester goes on.
We have just a little
office across the hall here
that includes a couple
of edit stations.
And we keep regular
hours in there.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: That's
where all the equipment is.
CHRIS BOEBEL: That's also where
you will be checking equipment
in and out of.
And there are also edit
facilities available
just downstairs in--
is it building 24?
26?
The new media center.
Some of you may--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: 26.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --be
familiar with it.
It's right downstairs.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
It's in your syllabus.
CHRIS BOEBEL: But anyway,
it's in your syllabus.
So that's who we are.
And do we want to
find out who they are?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, so
let's just go around the room
first, if you just
want to say your name
and what your interests are.
And actually, even before
we go around and introduce
yourselves, just to tell
you a little bit about how
this class works, in
case you're wondering
what you're getting into.
We'll just tell you
really, really quickly,
and then we're going to
jump right into things.
And then at the
end of class, we're
going to go over the
syllabus in detail
and the different
logistical issues,
like how you check out film
equipment and other kinds
of things.
But so basically, the
way this class works
is we meet twice a week.
So we have this Wednesday
night class for three hours
and then there's
the lab on Friday.
And it's a big time
commitment for students.
I guess compared not to
some other classes, perhaps.
CHRIS BOEBEL: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But we've tried
to arrange the
class in such a way
that it doesn't add any
additional time to what
you would normally
be doing in a class.
Part of the idea
with the lab is some
of what you would be doing
in the lab you would be doing
on your own anyway,
but this way, you
could do it with
supervision, with help,
which is really
important as people
are learning how to do stuff.
So we don't presume that
people have any background
in doing video work.
CHRIS BOEBEL: If you do--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
when you go around--
CHRIS BOEBEL:
--that's wonderful.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: --you
can talk about it.
Yeah, if you do, that's fine.
But even in the
last class, we had
students who had
some background,
but the background varied.
So maybe somebody had done some
photography or somebody had
done this, but then
they didn't necessarily
know about other things,
like sound or about editing
or whatever it is.
So we don't presume
any kind of background.
So we have the
Wednesday night class.
We have the Friday class.
We also try, with the
Wednesday night class,
we do have readings
for the class,
but we've tried to keep
them relatively contained.
It's kind of hard because
there's lots of readings,
but we've worked very
hard to keep the reading
reasonable for the class.
So again, because you're
going to be spending
a lot of time doing
production work,
we don't want it all
just to accumulate.
So the readings are short.
A lot of the readings might
be interviews with filmmakers,
for example.
So we've tried to find things
that are relatively good reads.
I think we have
only one graduate
student, [? Catarina. ?]
So you're responsible also
for the recommended reading,
as well as the required.
So the rest of you, it would
just be the required reading
that you would be expected
to do before class.
And so anyway, so we've tried
to keep things contained
in terms of time commitment.
Anyway, so that's just a few
of the most basic things.
And then at the
end of the class,
we'll talk more, again, about
how it's actually set up
and kind of what kinds
of exercises and projects
you're expected to do over
the course of the class.
And the Wednesday night class,
what we do in that class
is we watch clips from
classic documentaries that
are addressing certain kinds of
issues we want to talk about.
And they're really
discussion-based.
So it's you responding to the
clips based on the readings,
having conversations about that.
And then the Friday
class is the one
that's the production class.
So that's the lab part.
That's where you're
really learning
how to use the equipment.
But you're also going to be
given different exercises.
And we try to make
the exercises really
link up with what we've been
talking about in the Wednesday
class, theoretically.
So for example, if in a
Wednesday class we're talking
about cinema verite-- you
might not know what that is,
that's totally fine--
if we're talking about that as a
certain kind of film technique,
we might send you out to
do a little assignment
around MIT that's a
cinema verite technique.
So we try to make the
production and the theory
part of the class always
link up and work together.
OK?
I'm sorry, you were
going to add something.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh,
I was just going
to say, as far as the
way the class is set up
and what the expectations are,
again, we don't necessarily
assume that anybody has any
kind of video or production
experience.
If you do, that's wonderful, and
we can work at whatever level
you are at.
But for those of you who might
have production experience,
you know there's a
very steep learning
curve to this stuff when
you start out doing it.
And that's what the
purpose of the lab
is, as well, that it's a
fairly intensive time when
we can work with and get
you over a lot of the really
basic mistakes that everybody
makes when they start out.
And if you've already
made those mistakes
and you're at a
further advanced level,
we can adjust to make
sure that you are working
at whatever level you're at.
So--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: I'm sorry, I
keep standing in front of you.
CHRIS BOEBEL: That's OK.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
[INAUDIBLE] anyway, OK,
so the way we're going
to do tonight's class
is the first half
of class, I'm going
to give a bit of
a general overview
and then Chris is going to give
a bit of a general overview.
And then we're going
to break for a bit,
and then we're
going to come back
and we're going to hop right in.
And we're going to start
talking about early science
documentaries in the 1890s
and watching some clips that
are really fun and interesting.
Hopefully it will
be quite enjoyable.
But because there's a lot to
do over the semester, which
turns out to be really short,
we're going to just hop
right in.
So anyway, so just
the overview, a bit
of an overview first of some of
the major ideas in the class.
So this class is about
documentary filmmaking
about science and technology,
however we want to define that,
but it's also about
thinking through ideas
through the process of
making documentary films.
And a lot of classes that
focus on film or video
tend to split into
here's the theory classes
that analyze things and
here's the production
class that teach you how to
do the hands-on end of things.
And this class, we've
tried to set it up
to really counter that.
I mean, our idea is that
you can't separate out
the ideas from how you actually
go about making things.
So we want to constantly,
through the process of making,
be thinking about the
ideas at the same time, put
that all back together.
And we would argue that, in
order to really understand
and think about
documentary films,
you also have to know about how
they're actually getting made.
So even if you're less
interested in the production
and then more interested
in just understanding
documentary filmmaking,
knowing how they're made
can completely
transform how you think
about documentary filmmaking.
So that's another
benefit of the class.
And just to give
one example of this
that I remember when I was
at NYU, we were both at NYU--
I was in anthropology, Chris
was in the film school--
but when I was a
graduate student at NYU,
there was a documentary
filmmaker, Tony Buba, who came.
I don't if you've
ever heard of him.
He did these interesting little
documentary avant garde films.
And he did one
called Lightning Over
Braddock, which is about
unemployed steelworkers
in Pennsylvania.
And he had this--
he would have this
discussion with
some unemployed steelworkers.
And one of the guys had on
his hat the Tom Cruise film--
Top Gun was really
popular at the time,
so he had a Top Gun hat on.
And afterwards, one
of the NYU graduate
students who was
in cinema studies,
and he had been trained to
think about film as texts,
so largely thinking
about, well, what
do things mean symbolically.
And so he was asking Tony
Buba afterwards, well,
what did you mean by having
this guy wear the Top Gun hat?
What did that symbolize?
And Tony Buba was like,
it didn't mean anything.
I didn't ask the guy
to take off his hat.
I mean, you know?
[INAUDIBLE]
So it is often
possible when thinking
about documentary films to
overread or overanalyze.
And so what we're trying
to encourage in this class,
instead of thinking about
documentary filmmaking
primarily as text or
analyzing it in that way,
is thinking about documentary
filmmaking as a process.
Right?
How do you go about
making documentary films?
What are the social
relationships
that are involved?
And we would argue that
potentially a more helpful way
of thinking about documentary
filmmaking as a process
is thinking about
it in terms of being
a social negotiation
between the filmmakers,
the subjects of the documentary
films, and the audiences.
Right?
So how do the films
come into being?
How do they circulate?
How are they interpreted?
What's the kind of
social negotiation
among all these different
kinds of players?
And there's both a documentary
filmmaker and theorist,
David MacDougall, who
argues that there's
three ways to think
about this relationship
between documentary filmmakers
and their subjects, the people
that they're filming.
And do you have the PowerPoint?
Do we have-- do we
have a PowerPoint?
Sorry.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Sorry.
We have two PowerPoints.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: We
have two PowerPoints.
So the first one.
So he gives this
kind of nice little--
or different ways of thinking
about this that I think
can be helpful.
And he argues that
there's three ways
of thinking about this
camera/subject relationship,
one he refers to
as the responsive
camera, one the reactive camera,
one the interactive camera.
And he argues that
some documentary films
can have all of them
going on at the same time.
But what does he mean by
these, the responsive camera?
What he argues for
documentary filmmakers,
the responsive camera is
when the filmmaker is really
trying to respond to what's
going on with the subjects.
So if you have a
documentary filmmaker
who's doing a documentary on--
it could be any kind of topic,
but that documentary filmmaker
is really trying to
figure out what's
going on from the point
of view of the subjects
that they're working
with and take
their cues from the subject.
And maybe the pacing of the film
is going to be based on that.
So for example, it
could be-- give me
a good example of a film.
It could be about a
dance group, for example.
So what is the documentary
filmmaker doing?
Is the documentary
filmmaker really responding
to what's going on
among this group,
and just sort of following
along and allowing
the pacing and the timing
of what's being shot
or what gets edited later to
come out of what's going on
with that group and the
filmmaker's relationship
to that group?
So is the filmmaker
largely responding
to what's going on
with the subjects?
That's one way of thinking about
that film/subject relationship.
Another way to think about
it is the interactive camera.
OK?
And he argues this is
when the relationship
between the filmmakers
and the subjects
is largely about their
interaction in relationship
with the camera.
And an example of this is
the filmmaker John Rouch
who we're going to talk
about later in class.
But John Rouch films
were meant to be
collaborations
between his subjects
and himself as a filmmaker.
And so he would work with
people and they would kind of
improvise topics and then he
would have-- sometimes you
would have young people acting
on their lives, for example.
And so they were meant
to be interactive
dialogues almost between people,
where people improvised things
that ended up being
filmed so that's
a very kind of
interactive camera,
right, a different
kind of relationship.
And then the third one
being what he refers
to is the constructive camera.
And that's when
the filmmaker uses
bits of images,
different kinds of shots,
and puts them together according
to a pre-established logic.
So for example, if
you want to make
a film about a particular
topic, whatever it might be.
And you already have an idea,
this is what I want to argue.
You might go out
and look for images
that fit the argument that
you already want to make.
And then you put the
images into your sequence
in that kind of order.
And so David MacDougall argues
that all of them are valid.
And you can make
a good documentary
based on any one of
those different modes.
And he argues that
some filmmakers
might shift between
all of those modes even
in the course of one
documentary film.
But it's kind of
helpful, conceptually,
to think about there's
all these different kinds
of relationships you can have
as a filmmaker with the people
that you're working with.
And none of them is wrong.
You can, again, do
really interesting things
with any one of them.
But it's just helpful to
differentiate in our thinking
some of these different
kinds of relationships.
And thinking about
documentary as a process
and not just focusing on the
films as the end product,
but thinking about things
in perceptual terms also
encourages us to ask
certain kinds of questions
that we might not ask otherwise.
And we'll be talking
about this more
over the course of the class.
But also thinking about
film as a process,
and thinking about these
kinds of relationships between
filmmakers, subjects,
and audiences, can also--
if you do want to make
documentary films--
can cause you to ask
certain kinds of questions
as you think about the process
of making documentary films.
So what kinds of topics
do you want to focus on?
What kinds of
relationships do you
want to create as a
filmmaker with your subjects
or with your audiences?
What kinds of tools would you
use to focus on those topics
or to create those
kinds of relationships?
So when you think about
documentary filmmaking
as a process, you start
thinking about all those kinds
of questions, I think,
at a deeper level.
So in this class, we're going
to be encouraging you to think
about a range of questions.
And let me just throw a few out.
One is what is this three-way
relationship between filmmaker,
subjects, and audiences?
We want to be
constantly thinking
about that when we watch films,
when we talk about films, when
you're out actually
shooting stuff,
thinking about
that relationship.
Secondly, what's the
larger social setting
in which the documentary
films are being made?
And how does the shape the
film and how the film ends up
being interpreted?
So what's the larger social
setting when things get made?
Number three, what's
happening outside the frame
of the camera?
And David MacDougall in
an earlier book of his,
he has this wonderful quote
about documentary film.
And he says that if you
think about the viewfinder
of a camera, that
it's the opposite
of the viewfinder of a gun.
And what he means by that is
that if you look through--
if you imagine a soldier
looking through the viewfinder
of a gun, the idea is to
frame an image in order
to annihilate whatever is
in the sights of the gun.
But he argues with a camera,
you aim in order to focus on--
you aim your image.
But the point of
doing that is not
to annihilate
what's in the frame,
but to but to preserve
whatever is in the frame.
But in the act of preserving
what's in the frame,
you annihilate everything
else outside of it.
So that's what you have.
That's what remains is
what it is that you shot.
But everything else,
the larger context
that was happening around
what was being shot
gets completely lost and
annihilated in the process.
And one of the
things that we want
to be thinking about when we
think about documentary films
is, what's all that
stuff outside the frame
that often we don't
end up talking about?
And the fourth thing
is how does the process
of going about making
a documentary film?
And the kinds of
aesthetic choices people
make, the kinds of
production choices,
how do they shape the kinds of
questions that you want to ask?
OK, so what ideas get conveyed?
How do people
interpret the film?
So once again, we're
basically arguing
that you can't separate out
the doing from the thinking,
that you can't separate
out the filmmaking
from the kinds of ideas
that you want to convey.
And that we want to
be thinking about
these all at the same time.
And so one final thing I
just want to throw out here--
so in this class we think
about documentary film
as a construction.
And often when people think
about documentary film,
often there's a tendency
to get caught up
in debates about
whether something
is objective or subjective,
whether the filmmaker is being
objective enough
or whatever it is.
And we would argue
that it's more
helpful to think about all
documentary films as being
constructions.
And by that, we don't mean--
sorry-- and by that we don't
mean that certain documentaries
aren't more accurate than others
because they clearly can be.
Obviously some films
can be far more accurate
than other kinds of
documentary films.
Some can be far more
perceptive than others.
Some documentary films
might be completely
distorting and problematic.
But saying those
kinds of things is
different from saying that
something is not objective
because it's saying
something's not--
if you want to say
something's objective,
it's implying basically,
that with the camera,
you can somehow just make a
record of the world and somehow
not bring yourself and your own
interpretations to whatever it
is that you're looking at.
And is that really
possible for any of us
to be able to do that?
And so it's more
helpful, I think,
if we think of it in
terms of constructions.
It's acknowledging that
what people do with a camera
is not just a
recording of the world,
but it's an interpretation
of the real world.
That there's always
in the act of making
these things in the act of
it being a construction.
It's always an
interpretation of the world
out there through the choices
that documentary filmmakers
make, in terms of what you
choose to focus on, how
you choose to edit something.
And I've heard some
people argue, well,
would you put a
camera on a tripod
and just let it run, and
isn't that objective?
But nobody wants to sit around
and watch 12 hours of footage.
No one will watch that.
In order to make anything that
anybody would want to watch,
you have to-- you're
telling something.
You want people to pay
attention to something.
So even if it's only focusing
on certain kinds of things
and excluding
others, you're trying
to get whoever your viewers are
to pay attention to something
and to focus on something
and not something else.
So there's always
processes of interpretation
that are involved.
And there's always the
element of documentary films
being constructions.
And again, we'll talk a
lot about it in films.
And again, you got a
lot of documentary films
that are not such good
documentary films,
and others that are
really great ones,
and some that are more accurate,
and others that are not.
But they're all
constructions in some sense.
So we just want to
keep that in mind.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So as we said at
the beginning, no experience,
a little experience,
even a lot of experience,
we can adjust the
class to match.
I mean, it sounds like we've
got a pretty good group with--
nobody has come in saying, well,
I've been in 30 film festivals.
So that's good.
And again, we're
here as a resource.
The equipment's
It's a really exciting thing to
start making films and videos.
It's very addictive,
just to warn you,
for those of you
who haven't done it.
And we'll see how it goes.
Yeah, go ahead.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: One thing
that is a prelude to what Chris
is going to say--
one thing I forgot to mention
at the end-- in addition
to thinking about
documentary filmmaking
as a process, the
other end of the class,
I neglected to mention
the science end of it,
that this class is also partly
drawing on an STS perspective.
So for those of you who aren't
a Science Technology Society.
I mean you're studying
it, [? Katarina's ?]
in the graduate program,
history, anthropology, science,
technology, and society.
But basically, it's
a social science--
focus on science and technology.
And one of the
things that STS has
been very helpful at offering
is thinking about science itself
as a process.
How do you think about
science as a process?
So basically what this
class is trying to do
is think about
documentary filmmaking
as a process and
science as a process,
and trying to bring
them all together.
And so we're focusing on
documentaries about science.
But also we're going
to be encouraging
you to do your final
projects about science,
engineering-related
topics, broadly defined.
You can define that in all
different kinds of ways.
But we're trying to bring both
of those perspectives together.
And just to mention very briefly
just some of the questions
that we're going to be
asking on that end--
is how has science been captured
in documentaries in the past?
What kinds of ways?
What kinds of narratives
get told about science?
What kinds of narratives might
get left out about science?
How have scientists themselves
use visual images and also
other kinds of media
and towards what ends?
And what's the kind
of back and forth
between science and other
kinds of filmmaking,
or between fiction
and documentary, even?
So for example, if we're
going to have class on science
fiction, thinking about the back
and forth between documentary
and fiction filmmaking and
science and literature,
for example.
So just wanted to
throw that out as well.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So I'm going to
just go through and give you
just a quick tour
of a couple of--
several things that will be
thinking about in greater
detail later in the class.
And I take a filmmaker's
perspective on things.
And I should say when I say
filmmaker or making a film,
I'm using that
interchangeably with video,
because, really, the medium is--
people who love film would
kill me for saying this,
but it's somewhat
irrelevant at this point.
Most films at one
time or another
spend a lot of
their life on video,
even if they originate
on film because they're
edited on video.
They're even projected on video.
And increasingly, they're
just completely done on video,
even when we think
of them as films.
And we can talk about the
distinction in greater detail.
But just so you know, when I say
filmmaker, I mean this stuff.
So Chris talked
about filmmaking,
video making as a process.
And I want to go through
and just talk about a couple
of the things that we're going
to be thinking about when
we examine that process.
So let's just start
out by thinking
about what's interesting,
different, or particularly
quote unquote "special"
about the process of making
visual images?
And obviously, film, video
is not the first medium
that people have used
to make visual images.
I mean, from cave
painting onward,
people have been
making visual images.
And other people have
been interpreting them.
I'm sure there
were people sitting
around looking at
the cave paintings
and analyzing them,
and judging which
was more interesting,
which was more
representational or better.
So it's been around
for a long time.
And before we
actually start talking
about film and
documentary films,
I wanted to take a quick look
at a couple of paintings.
And I'm not an art
historian by any means.
I'm not even beginning
to try to present
any kind of introduction to
thinking about paintings.
But I picked a
couple of paintings
by one particular artist
that I found really, really
interesting and an interesting
entre into some of the issues
that we're going to be
talking about in film.
So does anybody
recognize this painting?
That's better,
yeah, much better.
So any guesses?
Any ideas?
So it's an artist that you may
or may not know much about,
but you've probably almost
certainly seen his work.
It's Hieronymus Bosch.
And the painting is called The
Seven Deadly Sins and the Four
Last Things.
And the four small circles
in each of the corners
are the four last things, death,
judgment, hell, and glory.
So you've got death up
there, you've got judgment,
I think, down there,
hell and glory up there.
And then the seven deadly sins
are the ones that we've heard.
Wrath as at the bottom.
And then proceeding
clockwise you've
got envy, greed, gluttony,
sloth, lust, and pride.
And then in the center
is the eye of God
who's seeing everything.
And that's I think Jesus
rising from the tomb
in the very center.
So one of the things that I
really like about this painting
is that it's kind of an
attempt to capture motion.
It looks like one of
those spinning disks,
like viewer disks.
So if you look at
it like this, it's
kind of telling a
story in a certain way.
And you can kind
of spin it around
and spin it around, and so on.
And I guess what that means,
which is kind of interesting,
is that God is the audience.
But what also I think is
interesting about Hieronymus
Bosch's work is it says
a lot about the role
of the visual artist and
the way they interpret
the world or their subject.
So the first thing about
his paintings is that--
and I don't know, again,
you may or may not
have been exposed to them.
This is not certainly
one of his famous ones
we don't actually have
a lot of his paintings
that we know of that
exist right now.
But they tend to
be very accessible.
They're very circulated.
Even if you don't
know that you're
looking at a Bosch painting,
you probably have seen them.
And we're going to look
at another one that's
much more famous in a moment.
They are very striking.
They have a very, very strong
kind of view of the world.
And you don't really
need to a lot about him
or his world in order
to look at them,
analyze them, interpret them.
In fact, we really don't know
much about Hieronymus Bosch
at all.
He was a painter of
religious allegories
and one of a school
of Flemish painters.
But he's the only one
that anyone really
knows at all widely.
I mean it was a very specific
genre that flourished
at a very specific time.
And the rest of them
are in museums or lost.
And his, as you'll see,
that one in particular,
is extremely quoted
as a visual artifact.
And I think that one of the
reasons for that, which you'll
see in a few minutes,
kind of interprets
or carries over with filmmakers
is that his view of the world
has a very powerful
internal logic.
It's very, very specific.
And it's a combination of
conventional religious allegory
and things that are really,
uniquely identifiable.
Things that are hallucinogenic,
disturbing, shocking even,
nightmarish, and that is
kind of unique to him.
And from painting to painting,
that's very recognizable.
So he's got this body of work
that is internally consistent.
And ha has a very,
very specific view
of the world that kind of
pushes through all of his work.
And again and again,
you'll see that
with filmmakers,
particularly filmmakers
that we know and talk about.
They have a really specific
way of looking at the world.
And they push that view on
their audience, on others.
Sometimes they don't make
great mentors or instructors
because they have this
very, very powerful view
of the world.
But it's also, if
they are successful,
it's very accessible.
And it's and it's
very consistent.
If you go to see a
Martin Scorsese movie,
you have a feeling what
you're going to get,
and most of the time you're
right, even if the films are
very different.
In some ways, there is this kind
of very specific and internally
consistent view.
So the next painting here is
another Bosch, and it's-- oops,
actually this is a little
detail that kind of shows you
the nightmarish
melodrama that you see.
This is wrath.
And you've got these little
psychodramas is playing out.
Another great thing, if you're
going to be a filmmaker,
have melodrama,
action, violence.
You know it always works.
This is the painting, though,
that you may have seen,
The Garden of Earthly Delights.
And it's a really enormous
and complicated work.
You've got hell,
purgatory, and paradise.
And it's a triptych
painting, three panels,
just enormous and
enormously complicated.
And I think it's a really
great way of introducing
another concept that's
going to be really
central to this class,
both in terms of the films
we talk about and the theory
we talk about and the clips
we watch, and also what
we do in our own work,
and how we develop
as filmmakers.
And that is the
frame, the frame.
As Chris mentioned, the
question of what you frame up
in your camera is
really central,
because as David
MacDougall says,
you're making a choice there.
And you're
annihilating everything
that's not in your frame.
And so what you do, what you
choose, the choice you make,
is really, really crucial.
But the frame also extends
beyond just that simple concept
of the frame.
The frame is also what
subject did you choose
to film in the first place?
What style are
you filming it in?
What kind of internal
logic do you as a filmmaker
bring to your subject?
What's your point of view, maybe
your political point of view
or your social point of view?
What is going on in the
social world around you
that may or may not
affect the film,
or may or may not appear
overtly in the film,
but affects the
film in other ways?
So the frame is kind of
this overarching idea
that really defines
and determines
the kinds of films we all make.
And the really simple
way to think about it
is just literally
what's in the frame.
But that frame and
those questions
kind of extend beyond.
What I see in this painting,
which is really, really
interesting, and I
think says something
about Hieronymus
Bosch as a painter,
is I see a desire to cram
everything into the frame.
It's like, I don't want
to leave anything out.
I just want everything in there.
And the detail just is maniacal.
It just goes down to this
really extreme level.
And very often, when people
look at this painting,
they don't look at
it like this, they
don't see the whole
painting, because it's often
shown as a detail.
The most famous panel
is hell on the right.
You may have just seen that.
And some people don't know that
it's part of a larger work.
They just see that
panel because it's
full of all this
really shocking, kind
of graphic imagery.
And it's often the rest
of it's often deleted.
And if you think
about it, that's
kind of what you
might do with a film.
If you were making
a film about Bosch,
and you chose to only
focus on that panel,
you could just erase
completely the other two
and annihilate them.
And that is exactly what
MacDougall is talking about.
It even goes beyond that though.
Sometimes you just see
details of the hell panel.
This is a classic one here.
See all sorts of terrible things
happening to the damned souls.
And if you search
online for Bosch,
for his work, a lot of times
you'll get things like this.
So here, we're not even
seeing all of hell.
We're just seeing
little details.
And again, if you
think about making
a film about this painting
or about his work,
think about what you
would put in the frame,
literally, like this, but
also in terms of how would
you approach it.
Would it be a biographical
portrait of him
as a painter and a person?
We don't really
know much about him,
so that would be difficult.
Would it be an academic
study of the structure
and the form of the painting?
Would it locate him historically
in his time and his era?
Or would it be kind of a
personal response piece
where you, as the filmmaker,
as another artist,
respond to his art.
All of those are
very, very valid ways
of approaching a
film about Bosch.
And all of them entail a
completely different frame.
And all of them would
be completely different.
And some might be
better than others.
Some might be
fairer than others.
Some might be more
accurate than others.
But that would be more a matter
of the skill of the filmmaker
and the filmmaker's
willingness to engage
with the subject
in an honest way.
There's absolutely
nothing wrong with making
any one of those films.
So again, it's about frame.
It's about what you've
put in the frame,
and also what your mental frame
is, what your mental space is
vis a vis your subject.
So enough about painting,
something I very little about.
But I would just
take away, again,
this idea that people have
been trying to figure out
how to visually represent the
world for a really, really
long time.
And sooner or later,
it always ends up--
you always end up with
the basic quandary
of how do you take something
as big and complex as the world
and drill down and distill it
into something as comparatively
simple and feeble as an image
or a series of images or a film.
And you do that by
your these choices
you make as you
frame your subject.
So I'm going to move on
and look at a few clips.
And these are clips that we've
picked for a couple of reasons.
They're all science
documentaries, or most of them,
in one form or another.
A lot of them have
an MIT connection.
But they also I think do an
interesting job of illustrating
different approaches,
different quote
unquote "frames"
of seeing the world
or seeing science, again
in quotes, I guess.
And they also--
I'm not really big
on presenting kind
of an evolutionary perspective,
like this film superseded
that one and it was better
because it was more advanced.
But there is kind of
responsiveness, a call
and response to these films
as you proceed through time
and you see one filmmaker
responding to and sometimes
responding against the
work that went before.
So let me show you
the first clip.
This is a clip from
a film made here
at MIT by a predecessor of mine,
I guess, in the early 1950s.
It's called Making
Electrons Count.
And it's on Project
Whirlwind which
was one of the very first
digital computers developed
by Jay Forrester here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- MIT is best known for the
scientists and engineers
who have studied there.
On the edge of the campus is
the digital computer laboratory,
home of Project Whirlwind.
This project
started in 1947 when
JW Forrester and
his associates began
the design of an ultra
high-speed electronic digital
computer, which they
christened Whirlwind 1.
Whirlwind first
operated in 1950.
This laboratory's
primary concern
has been the development
and application
of reliable and
efficient computer
components and systems.
By 1953, Whirlwind could
perform 25,000 multiplications
per second.
In addition to its extensive
use in research connected
with our defense program,
about half of Whirlwind's time
has been dedicated
to the solution
of scientific and engineering
problems of all kinds.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: OK, oops.
So what do you notice about
that in terms of technique?
AUDIENCE: Getting the feel the
[INAUDIBLE] Was [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Propaganda feel--
so that's a value judgment,
which is totally--
I mean I agree with
you, but why does
it have that propaganda feel.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
just like the voice is
less say personal [INAUDIBLE]
things like advertising
[INAUDIBLE] so it's
less [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right, yeah,
I mean it's basically
it's an illustrated script.
How did they make that film?
Somebody wrote up
what they wanted
to say about Project Whirlwind.
And then they went
out and they filmed
shots that sometimes don't even
really illustrate the script.
I mean they're just kind of
general, random shots of people
wandering around
this computer, right?
And they're just
filling the time.
So they have a script.
They recorded it, no
particular voice, as you said.
It's just what's called
the voice of God narration.
And then they went out and
they filmed x number of shots
that they needed in order
to fill up that space.
And I unfortunately
lost my place,
I'm going to play
it again quickly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Who have studied there.
On the edge of the
campus is the digital--
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: So static
camera, barely moving.
Here, whoa, a pan,
very, very daring.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --ultra high speed
electronic digital computer,
which they christened
Whirlwind 1.
Whirlwind first
operated in 1950.
This laboratory's
primary concern
has been the development
and application
of reliable and
efficient computer
components and systems.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: We see people
but we don't meet the people.
We don't know their names.
We have no idea what they think
about this or who they are
or what they're really doing.
We know they're typing
at a typewriter.
Sometimes we don't
even know that
much about what they're doing.
It's really an
illustrated text document.
So the next piece
I'm going to show you
is a short clip from
a television program
from around the same
time called See It Now
that is also about
the same topic.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
has developed a new
one for the Navy.
It's a Whirlwind
electronic computer.
With considerable
trepidation, we
undertake to interview
this new machine.
Now to MIT and the computer lab
at Cambridge, Massachusetts--
Hello, New York.
Hello, New York,
this is Cambridge.
And this is the oscilloscope
of the Whirlwind
electronic computer.
I assume that like any
delicate, finely tuned piece
of mechanism, this has a human
element involved too, has it?
- Yes, Mr. Murrow.
I'm Jay Forester, director of
the digital computer laboratory
where Whirlwind was built.
- Well, I wonder if we could
take a look around, sir?
- Yes, let's first look
at one of the storage
tubes such as the
Whirlwind uses for memory.
Whirlwind stores in
these tubes information
in 25 millionths of a second.
And further down
the row, you can
see some of the
electronic circuits which
make Whirlwind work.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: So what do
you notice about that one?
Thoughts?
AUDIENCE: It's a lot--
[INAUDIBLE] that takes a lot
more personal like actually
get to see the face of
the person who's talking.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Jay
Forrester, the person
who's in charge--
primarily in charge
of development of this machine.
AUDIENCE: He actually did--
and he gives context
to what you're saying.
It's not just a random
pan or something
like that, the environment.
But he's like, oh, yeah, in
this shot, we're showing this,
and [INAUDIBLE]
we'll show you this.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: The
sound is different.
[INAUDIBLE] Like music
in the background.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Generic
music, again, I
mean it's just kind of like
feel like they measured out
the tape.
Like, well, we need
100 feet of music here.
And then they got it, done.
And they cut it.
Yeah, I mean, this
one is-- it's drama.
First of all, they're
create-- they're
trying to create drama, right?
I mean, it's the magic
of live television.
This is Edward R. Murrow,
this was an extremely famous
broadcast--
extremely famous early
television program.
And he's bringing you
magically, magically
into a laboratory at MIT
to meet Jay Forrester
and meet the Whirlwind computer.
But it's still pretty
scripted, right?
It's still pretty stiff.
And it's personality driven,
but it's also very formal.
It's written, obviously.
I mean, he's seems to have his
lines memorized, certainly,
or Edward R. Murrow has
his lines memorized.
But as in terms of something
that is compelling,
and I mean if you can get
over the technological gap
between what we're used
to seeing and this,
it's a lot more
compelling to a viewer
to watch this than to
watch the other one,
which is just this very kind of
text with pictures and images.
So I want to read a
quote from a filmmaker--
a pretty famous filmmaker, film
producer-- named Robert Drew.
And it's specifically
about See It Now,
which was, as I said, a
popular series at the time.
So this is what Drew, who
was a contemporary, said.
"I tuned in to watch
Murrow's See It Now.
As the program progressed,
I turned off the sound
and watched the picture.
The progression disintegrated.
What power had been there
turned to confusion.
The logic left.
When I turned the picture off
and listened to the sound,
the program tracked perfectly.
Later that year, Murrow's
television programs
were printed in book form.
They read very well."
So again, what he's saying is
that, although obviously it's
a lot further along than,
visually and in terms
of drama, than the first
piece we looked at,
it's still really, really
audio and text-based.
And if you think about it, we
just watch it without sound
as I got back to my
place, you wouldn't
know what was going on, other
than the sign that says MIT,
and it's something
about a computer.
You wouldn't have any kind of
sense of human drama going on
or what these people
were engaged in or why.
And again, I personally
am not criticizing the use
of audio or reliance on audio.
But there's a strand in
filmmaking that says,
well, films are about images.
They are visual artifacts.
And you can't have a painting
about sound or painting
that relies on sound where
the painting, the image
is irrelevant, although that's
kind an interesting idea.
Now in conceptual
art, now we could.
But in traditional
painting, you couldn't.
So why would you in film?
So Drew and some other
people got very interested.
And they were
drawing on a number
of historical precursors.
I got very interested in another
kind of documentary filmmaking,
a documentary filmmaking that
would privilege the visual
and the experiential, the
sensory, over the text,
over what was being said, either
in an interview or a script.
And we're going to show
a quick clip of one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- They looked much
better last night--
He has lost weight.
And he was on that
panel this afternoon
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- It was good on--
[CROWD CHATTER]
- Not even for you, I must say.
- --on his own record.
- That's right.
- You can't rely
on your own record,
you haven't got any
business running.
- Right, that's right.
[CROWD CHATTER]
- Thank you very much.
Oh, thanks a lot.
- My pleasure.
- Thank you very much.
[CROWD CHATTER]
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
[CROWD CHATTER]
- We've got a candidate that
isn't afraid to take criticism.
- Listen, not only that--
- [INAUDIBLE] now, you'll
have the Senator all worn out.
[CROWD CHATTER]
- Please don't crowd
the senator, please.
- Let's keep moving there.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[CROWD CHATTER]
- Thanks again.
- Good luck, Jack.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: So what do
you notice about that one?
AUDIENCE: Well, I like the
way that it kind of takes
the perspective of
the Kennedys, just
masses of people just
running through their lives.
And they don't
actually see any faces.
It kind of gives you that
sense of just how many people
they were involved with.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Right, I like that.
Other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: They broke apart
the different aspects
of what they're
doing, handshaking,
Jackie O. repeatedly smiling,
and then the people walking up,
kind of sizing up the
situation before they actually
approached the Kennedys.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
So in terms of the
approach, I mean
you're all absolutely right.
It's about the experience
of being in that room,
particularly for Jackie
and to some extent for JFK.
This room-- you can
almost feel how hot
it is, how uncomfortable it is.
They're on display.
They're just being crowded
by all of these people.
They have to stand there
for who knows how long,
shaking hundreds of hands.
Jackie just looks
extraordinarily uncomfortable,
except when Robert Kennedy
comes through the line
and then he makes the joke.
And she seems
relieved for a second.
It's just-- it's all about
the experience of what it's
like to be on display, to
be kind of parading in front
of the common quote
unquote voter in Wisconsin,
trying to win the primary.
And the whole film
is built like that.
There isn't any voiceover.
There isn't any narration
really to speak of.
There are really very
few interviews, just
a little kind of maybe
snippets here and there.
Imagine what the Edward
R. Murrow version of that
would be.
Mr. Kennedy, how did it
feel being in that room?
Well, it was kind of hot.
But it was very exciting to
meet the voters of Wisconsin.
It would get at it in a
completely different way.
This is all about
the experience.
It's all about-- and it's also
about the drama in the story,
this unbearable
tension that kind of
keeps building and building.
And then RFK breaks the tension.
And then it builds again.
And let's watch
it without sound.
I mean the sound is
actually really cool.
I love the sound in the piece.
But visually, is constructed to
tell a story without the sound.
I think again, the sound
is really important.
But because these long, long
shots of the handshaking
and this sort of
demanding body language
that everybody
wants to touch them.
Everybody wants to grab them.
Just her, stoic-- but sort of
discomfort at the whole thing.
It all comes across, in
the crowding of the room,
just the whole feel of it, it
comes across without any sound
at all.
And I think that we're going
to actually in this class
start out looking at
some silent films.
And the thing that--
the standard thing to
say about silent films
is that it's so
wonderful to look at them
because they're pure
films, quote unquote.
They're just visual expressions
without any kind of audio
or any other kind of
supporting material.
And the idea of these verite
films is to in some way
recapture that even with
sound, even though the sound is
really important.
As a side note, this also
is an MIT connection.
It was shot by Ricky Leacock,
who was the head of MIT's film
program for about 20 years.
And it was edited by
DA Pennebaker who's
a very famous documentary
filmmaker, who
was I think a mechanical
engineering undergrad major
at MIT.
So the next piece is--
well, should we just pause?
Let's just pause.
OK.
So we're going to take
about a five-minute break
to change tape.
OK, so I want to
read another quote
from another filmmaker who is
then responding to this cinema
verite movement.
And the next filmmaker
we're going to look at
is Errol Morris.
Are people familiar with
Errol Morris's work?
Anybody?
So he's a filmmaker who's had
quite a bit of popular success,
at least for a
documentary filmmaker.
He's done a lot
of films that have
had a lot of commercial
distribution,
won an Academy Award, quite
a well-known filmmaker.
And his approach to
documentary filmmaking
is completely the opposite of
the Robert Drew cinema verite
approach.
And this is what he wrote
about that approach.
"What bothers me are the
metaphysical claims that
go with it, that somehow the
application of these techniques
will produce truth, as
though there's metaphysical--
there's this metaphysical
meat grinder,
which if you put the right
ingredients in and prepare them
according to some given process,
will magically produce truth.
That idea has always struck
me as complete nonsense.
It's a style.
And style doesn't
guarantee you truth.
When I was making my first
film, Gates Of Heaven--"
which we'll look at later--
"I would joke that I would
take all the basic principles
of verite and turn
them on their head.
Against that idea of
being a fly on the wall,
I would make myself as
obtrusive as possible.
I would put myself right
in front of the people
and force them to
look at the camera.
I would light everything instead
of using available light.
Instead of hand-held cameras,
I put everything on a tripod."
So he's basically saying--
he's reacting against
this kind of movement that
was a very powerful movement
within documentary film
and which was basically making
the assertion that we all
just kind of bought
into, including me,
and I'm not saying
we were wrong,
that this is kind of a way of
really getting into people's
lives and really
representing them
in a more accurate way
than some of these earlier
kinds of techniques
we were talking
about with the voice of God
narration and interviews
and so on.
Errol Morris said
no, no, no, no, no.
What I'm going to do is
interview-based films.
And I want to show you
clips from a couple
that he's worked on.
The first one is from a film
called Fast, Cheap, And Out
Of Control.
Anybody seen it?
It's a really, really
interesting film.
It basically weaves the stories
of four people together.
And it has this very,
very abstract point
about life and chaos and death
and decay and communities.
One of the people in the film is
Rodney Brooks, who is in CSAIL.
And the clip I'm
going to show is
a bit of an interview with him
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Evolution spent a long
time, billions of years,
getting to the point
of little creatures
which could chase each
other around, have mobility,
and interact with the
world in a meaningful way,
apart from being an amoeba that
just sits there and doesn't
do much.
Once that stuff was there,
all this other stuff
evolved very quickly.
Higher-level intelligence,
whatever that is,
is pretty easy once you have
the ability to move around,
hunt, chase.
They're the tough parts.
I don't believe it's possible to
have a disembodied intelligence
without a physical
connection to reality.
Everything we think, everything
in our thought process
is built around being
in touch with reality,
even the word "touch."
A cockroach has 30,000 hairs,
each of which is a sensor.
The most complex robot
we've built has 150 sensors
and it's just about killed us.
We can't expect to do as well
as animals do in the world
until we get past
that sensing barrier.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: So the film
basically interweaves
Rodney Brooks with several
other subjects, a lion tamer,
someone who is a topiary
gardener who trims hedges
into these very complex
animal shapes, someone
who studies mole rats,
and who am I forgetting?
AUDIENCE: Did you
say the lion tamer?
CHRIS BOEBEL: The lion tamer,
I guess that's it, yeah.
So again, it's about artifice
and nature and mimicking nature
and how various organisms
live in the world
and how they respond to
the reality around them.
So it's a very,
very abstract film.
And what he's trying to do
is communicate some sort
of very subtle
and specific ideas
that people like Rodney
Brooks have developed
over a number of years.
And the film's like 15 or
more years old at this point.
So a lot of the
technology is stuff
that is an early
version of stuff
that they're still working
on across the hall there.
And you'll see much more
advanced versions of it
in the little videos
that they produce.
But the whole point is that it's
about getting inside his head.
And yet, it's yet another
frame for documentary film.
And the whole film isn't just
about getting inside his head.
It's about getting
inside this idea.
It's about getting inside
an idea that, again,
is very, very abstract,
but also very, very
tactile and tangible.
How do we, as organisms,
and other organisms,
respond to each other and
respond to the world around us?
And what does that do?
How does that shape us
and our communities?
It's again a completely
different way
of doing a documentary film.
Again, I'm presenting it in
kind of an evolutionary way.
I'm not meaning
to do that at all.
Even the early stuff--
I mean, the script-based
filmmaking is alive and well.
People still do it.
And it's completely
appropriate for certain things.
It's just a different
kind of frame.
It's a different kind
of way of looking
at these ideas and the
choice you make in terms
of your aesthetics or
your approach are going
to be determined by who you
are as a filmmaker, who you
develop, who you turn
into as a filmmaker,
and also what your subject is
and what your interests are.
If you're Rodney
Brooks and you are--
or I mean if you're--
I'm sorry-- if
you're Errol Morris
and you're interested in
these ideas that are, again,
fairly metaphysical,
fairly abstract,
if you wanted to do that as a
verite film, what would you do?
Spend months or years sitting
in a lab filming people
doing repetitive tasks.
And you wouldn't really
arrive at the ideas
that you would be
trying to communicate.
On the other hand, if you're
doing something that's
very dynamic, like a
presidential campaign,
it makes a lot of sense
to use a verite technique.
I want to show one other Errol
Morris clip from a film that
is much more current.
It's about five years old,
called the Fog Of War,
which is essentially a profile
of Robert McNamara, who
is Secretary of Defense
during the Vietnam War.
And as you probably
know, the Vietnam War
still kind of hangs over our
politics in a lot of ways.
McNamara is a really
interesting figure
in that he was front and
center in the war effort
and made a lot of decisions
that people were extremely upset
with-- many, many people
were extremely upset
with around the world
and in this country.
People called him a war
criminal for things he did.
And then late in life, no
more than a few years ago
when he was in his early
80s, he kind of came
to a different understanding
about what he had done
and didn't quite kind of
accept blame or present himself
as someone who was guilty
of doing certain things,
but definitely ended up with a
much more complex understanding
of what he had done.
And the film is a
fascinating film.
He's the only person in it.
He's the only interview in it.
And it's really about a person,
a man, struggling with his past
and struggling to
make sense of it,
without fully accepting
maybe some of the things
that he may have done.
But I'm just going to
show a little clip of it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- While I was secretary,
we used what's
called Agent Orange in
Vietnam, the chemical
that strips leaves off of trees.
After the war it is claimed
that was a toxic chemical.
And it killed many individuals,
soldiers and civilians
exposed to it.
Were those who
issued the approval
to use Agent Orange criminals?
Were they committing a
crime against humanity?
Let's look at the law.
Now what kind of
a law do we have
that says these chemicals
are acceptable for use in war
and these chemicals are not?
We don't have clear
definitions of that kind.
I never in the world would have
authorized an illegal action.
I'm not really sure I
authorized Agent Orange.
I don't remember it.
But it certainly occurred--
the use of it occurred
while I was secretary.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: This
is Errol Morris,
he's really interested
in an internal state,
a man struggling with himself,
struggling with his past.
It's a film set in a person's
mind, in a lot of ways.
Even though it's about Vietnam,
it's about a very, very real
and horrifying event.
It's really in a lot of
ways set in McNamara's mind.
So his approach is
really, really interwoven
with what he's interested
in as a filmmaker, which
is interwoven with his
technique, what he puts
in the frame quote unquote.
And again, the last point
that I'll make with these
is that it's obvious-- it
should be apparent by now
that filmmakers are not
just in conversation
or they don't just
build a relationship
with their subjects.
They're also in conversation
with each other.
So Errol Morris is very
much defining himself as not
the cinema verite person.
And Robert Drew and
the other people
who pioneered verite in
the '60s were very much
defining themselves as not
the TV documentary producers.
We don't do talking
head documentaries.
And someone like Edward R.
Murrow was presenting himself,
and in fact he was, in print
as well, as a journalist,
as someone who actually went
out and got stories that
were dramatic and
human and real, as
opposed to these kind of
newsreel presentations
where everything was just
kind of laid on a platter.
So people define themselves in
opposition to what they like.
They emulate what
they like they like.
They define themselves
in opposition
to what they don't like.
And that's a conversation
that just goes on.
I want to show just a couple
of other quick clips, for which
I'm going to go to YouTube,
because I think it's worth
also talking about how
that conversation also
crosses genres.
It doesn't happen just
within documentary film
or commercial film.
But people obviously
are continually
affected by each other.
Has anybody seen
this next film I'm
going to show, Powers Of 10?
It's a classic
science documentary.
And it also has
an MIT connection.
It's narrated by
Philip Morrison.
I think it was made in 1977.
And he was a legendary
physics prof at MIT.
And it's a film
that is basically
designed to give people a
sense of, well, powers of 10.
But I'll just show it.
It's short and pretty cool.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
isn't this the one
that they used to have all
MIT undergraduates watch
when they entered?
CHRIS BOEBEL: They did
up until like, maybe
even the early '90s, all
MIT incoming freshmen
on their first or second
day had to watch this.
I think they all went
into Kresge and sat down
and watched this film.
And it's worth it.
It's very good.
I mean, keep in mind, that in
terms of the special effects,
it's made it's made
close to 40 years ago.
But it's a very,
very cool concept.
It's a really
interesting example
of illustrating visually
a fairly abstract
mathematical concept.
And I wanted to just quickly
show another clip that I
think is a fun takeoff on this.
Does anybody remember, or did
anybody see the Jodie Foster
movie Contact?
It's a science fiction
film in which Jodie Foster
gets to meet aliens.
I won't say any more than that.
This is the opening of
the film and the idea
is to give a general
audience a sense of how
radio waves or
television signals
travel away from the Earth
at the speed of light.
And aside from being
wildly scientifically
inaccurate, which
is kind of funny,
the film is-- it's just an
interesting kind of Hollywood
take off on powers of
10, I think clearly
inspired by Powers of 10.
So I didn't realize that
Saturn was 50 light years away
from Earth.
But I think that it's cool
for a couple of reasons.
One, it's obviously
inspired by Powers Of 10.
But also it's
really kind of gutsy
because I think it's one
of the only mainstream
commercial Hollywood
movies that I
know of that has actually
like a minute and a half
of absolute silence,
like nothing
on the soundtrack at
all, which is cool.
And I'm sure they
could care less
that they got the speed
of light completely wrong
and that it's very variable
and that the Volare from 1953
is traveling by Saturn.
But anyway, the main thing
I just wanted to point out
was that these ideas
travel and that's
something that you can take
advantage of in your own work.
You can steal from
whomever you like,
and certainly be influenced
by whomever you like.
We're going to be
looking at a lot of films
in this class, from classic
documentaries, from the 1920s
and '30s up through
stuff that was
posted on YouTube or TechTV just
a few weeks ago or whatever.
And all of this is stuff--
it's grist for the mill for you
to be influenced by.
And one of the whole points
of, again, looking at clips
and talking about
them and trying
to engage with the broad trends
and ideas in documentary film
on Wednesday night
is so that you
can come in on Friday
morning in the lab
and have that informing you as
you start playing with cameras,
learning about editing,
learning about sound recording.
Because that's
what makes it fun.
The technical side can
be very frustrating.
As I said, there is a
steep learning curve,
which we'll try to help you get
over as smoothly as possible.
But what's really,
really exciting
and fun is just being aware of
all the possibilities and all
of the power that you have
in the choices that you
make as a filmmaker.
So want to continue, then?
Or shall we take
another little break?
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So that was kind
of our overview on two ends.
Usually mostly when we have
our classes on Wednesday night,
it's basically going
to be discussion.
So this is more
lecturing than we're ever
going to do any point
other than the semester.
But just to get a bunch
of ideas and to get
you thinking about
things, that's
how we wanted to begin things.
So now we're just
going to jump right
in and we're going to start
out with looking at both some
very early film clips
that people would now
refer to as documentary,
although at the time
they weren't conceived
of as documentary.
The word documentary wasn't
really coined into the 1930s.
But we're going to be looking
at some early, very early,
some of the very first
film clips from the 1890s,
and then a little
bit after that,
some of the very first films
that were made about science,
documentary films, again
that we would refer
to as documentary films now.
Should I just hop in.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK.
OK, so we're just going to spend
a few minutes on the Lumiere
brothers.
I don't if any of you
have ever heard of them.
But you might already know
that film cameras were largely
invented in the 1890s.
But they were inspired
by older technologies.
So some of you might be familiar
with magic lanterns or lanterns
that had a candle inside.
But they might have
cutouts around it
in a circle that would
be projected onto a wall,
for example.
Or you had like flip books.
You know what flip books were?
Where you would have different
pictures, might be a horse
galloping, a horse in
different stages of running.
And then you'd have
different pictures.
And then you'd flip
them really fast
and would look like
the horse was moving.
So there were these earlier
kinds of technologies
that preceded film cameras.
But film cameras as a
technology were largely
invented in the 1890s.
There were a number of
inventors who were all
working simultaneously, trying
to beat each other to get
the film cameras out there.
But two of the
most famous people
that you're going to
hear about in relation
to this are the
Lumiere brothers,
and in particular Louis
Lumiere, who invented a camera
called the cinematograph.
And that's actually where
the word cinema comes from,
cinematograph.
That's where it comes from.
They were French.
This was in 1895, 1894, '95.
And one of the things
that we're going
to be discussing
throughout the class
is how particular technologies
get created because people
have the desire to do certain
things with those technologies.
But in turn, the
technologies that get
created then also
influence then what
people are able to do
with those technologies
and how they end
up getting used.
And so that's something
to be thinking about
with this kind of camera
and another camera
that we're going to see shortly.
The technology, the
invention itself strongly
shaped how the camera
was going to get used.
And we can show you an example
of this what the Lumiere.
This is some images
of the cinematograph.
OK, and what's
distinctive about it?
I mean anything you notice
just on looking at the camera?
And you're actually going to
be reading a very short chapter
about this for next week, which
will give you a little bit
more background information.
But one thing was that it was
made it was made out of wood.
It was relatively light.
It was about 16 pounds.
And so it was portable.
You could carry it around.
In addition to that, so you see
the guy with the camera there,
no electricity, right?
No cord.
It was hand-cranked.
So you didn't need
electricity to do it.
And also, something interesting
about this technology
was in addition
to being a camera,
it was also could be
converted into a projector
at the same time, and
also a film processor.
So you could-- use so you could
take images on it one day.
And the next day you could
project them to the audience
and show them images
of themselves.
And because it
was mobile, it was
possible to take it out in
the world and take it outside.
And actually was even
better to take it outside
because you needed light to
be able to take good images.
So it was actually
better if you were
outside using this invention.
And so because of this, many of
the very first film clips that
were taken with
this invention were
what were called actualities,
that film scholars often
refer to as actualities.
But you might think of
them as the precursors
to documentary film.
So they're little snippets
of daily life, sort of life
out on the fly, outside.
And again, the
camera's moving around.
The reels were really
small, so largely they
were one minute in the
1890s when these first film
clips came out.
And something else--
I don't think we have--
that's the only images
that we have the camera, right?
Something else that's
interesting to think about--
because there was a lot
of competition at the time
to invent the moving picture
camera, the Lumiere brothers,
their family had
had a photography--
and they made
photographic equipment.
So they had a factory in France.
They were business people.
They knew this was
going to be a big deal.
People were really
excited about it.
So they were very
keen business people
in terms of what they
did with the camera.
And so they started
doing showings
in Paris of some
of the very early,
the very first little
one-minute films that they shot.
And they did these
screenings in Paris
that caused a lot of interest.
And then they trained, I
forget exactly how many,
40, 50 people early on,
to use the cinematograph.
And then they sent
them out-- they
made enough of
these inventions--
and then they sent them
out all over the world.
So from the very beginning,
it was quite international.
I mean certainly all over
Europe, and in addition
to that, relatively
shortly thereafter,
they sent some of their
operators to Tunisia, to Egypt.
I'm trying to remember where
else they went, a number of--
India, Bombay from
very early on.
And so these operators,
they would go out
and they would film
what was going on
say in Bombay and the capital.
And then they would have--
they would rent a
theater for the next day.
And then they would
show to the audiences.
And they would advertise them to
the audiences come to yourself
on film.
And so you had these
huge lines, everybody
wanted to go see these things.
They created a huge buzz
all around the world.
And then after they
created a huge buzz--
until that point
they, had refused
to sell any of these cameras.
And then after
that, they started
manufacturing the
cameras and selling them
once they had
created a huge buzz.
So it was very keen business
strategy on their part,
how they did this.
CHRIS BOEBEL: You can think of
it as kind of an early YouTube.
I mean, it was.
Had a lot of the same
function as YouTube
and a lot of the same appeal.
You could see yourself on film.
And it also opened up
an ability to see others
and to see people living
on other continents
and other countries, people
from other cultures very,
very easily.
And it seemed almost
magical at the time.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, and
that international focus,
one thing to keep in
mind at the time this
was the 1890s was
also the height
of the European colonial period.
So also pretty quickly
documentary films
ended up become--
they were shown in the colonies
but they were also often showed
a certain vision of images of
the colonial powers in relation
to the natives, quote unquote,
who were in the colony.
So you have to keep in mind
it was very international.
But this was also the
international period
at that point, was a colonial
world where you had--
Europe was very dominant over
other parts of the world.
But in addition to that, I mean
there was a very strong impact
of these images.
So for example, if you
think about Bombay,
I don't know how many of
you watch Hindi films.
Are you interested in
watching Bollywood films?
Any of you have seen them?
So the Bombay film industry is
actually bigger than Hollywood.
And actually, at this point,
I believe the Nigerian film
industry has also surpassed
Hollywood in terms
of number of films per year.
Those are sort of more
films made on the fly.
But the Bombay film industry
is absolutely enormous.
And it has a very,
very long history
of filmmaking that goes back to
the early Lumiere operators who
went there with
the cinematograph
and we're showing things.
And then they developed their
own internal film industry
you coming out of that lineage.
But anyway, let's just
show a couple early, very
earliest clips, maybe some
sense of what got filmed.
So this is the Lumiere
photographic equipment factory,
so the workers leaving that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh, yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: You
want to pause that for--
CHRIS BOEBEL: So this is
one of the very early films.
And you may have heard
this apocryphal stories is
about audiences ducking
when the train goes by.
This is the actual
film that supposedly
had had audiences ducking to
get out of the way of the train
as it pulled in.
One of the things that
I think is really cool
about these films is that people
aren't used to being filmed.
They don't really
know what's going on.
So they're completely
unselfconscious.
They're not mugging they're
not awkward for the most part.
They're not ill at ease.
They're just doing what they do.
And they aren't really sure
what the guy with the wooden box
is doing.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: We're going
to pause for just a second.
I was just going
to let you watch
and then you could
comment on it later.
But that last one,
just to mention,
some people refer to that as
actually the first narrative
film in the sense that they
had kind of figured out
a little story plot that they
wanted to act out beforehand.
But there's one other one
I want to see, maybe--
Demolition of a Wall, OK.
OK, and what's interesting
about that one,
because the cameras
were cranked you,
can also run them in reverse,
or you could speed them up.
So this is something
that the operators would
do to amuse the audiences.
So with the demolition
of the wall,
they would have
the wall come down.
And then they would reverse and
have the wall go back up, which
was like a really big hit.
I thought that was really funny.
So you could speed things
up to make things funny.
We didn't show any
international ones.
We should show one.
I always get [INAUDIBLE].
I mean I don't think
I've seen that one.
New York, just for fun.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Panorama.
CHRIS BOEBEL: There's Union
Square, for those of you
who are familiar with New York.
Anyway, but there's
a number of them
also where you see royalty,
you see military troops
on maneuver.
You see just little
snippets of life.
And so these are some of
the very early actualities
that were made by the
Lumiere operators.
So just general
reactions comments
on things you thought
they were interesting?
Are they fun to watch?
Are they-- I mean
why are they fun?
Or anything surprising?
AUDIENCE: Home video--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, what
makes that home video-like?
AUDIENCE: It's kind of
little moments that are--
like if you were
related to them,
it being more valuable
to you [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah and there's--
actually, we didn't see
one, but there's one with--
I don't think it's
on this disk--
but there's one
of a sack raised.
I'm not sure if it was the
workers at the Lumiere factory,
who exactly it was.
But there's all these
guys in the sack race and
falling down and laughing.
And they're laughing
at the camera.
And they're totally mugging
it up for the camera.
And that definitely has
a home video quality.
So why does that have
a home video quality?
If you think back
to when we were just
talking about the David
MacDougall, the responsive
camera, the interactive camera,
it's an interactive camera.
Particularly early on,
with leaving the factory,
some people are looking and
then other people are not,
so you don't know how many
people are really aware of what
the contraption does yet.
But a little bit
later on, people
are very aware of what
this thing is doing,
and they really start
hamming it up for the camera.
So it's the sense of
this interactive camera
where people are not pretending
that the camera's not there.
They're interacting
with the camera.
And they think it's fun.
And this is that's something
that really switches later
with both fiction films and
documentary films, where they
both of them increasingly become
about creating interior worlds
where the focus in a
lot of fiction films
is about creating the
sense of an interior world,
where you're getting in some--
inside some other world.
And you don't want to
really have attention
being called to
the fact that this
is being filmed necessarily.
And a lot of
documentary film follows
that those ideas as well.
But early on, again,
there's no distinction
here between fiction film
and documentary film,
because this was just invented.
So the little bit with
the hose, acting that out,
I mean there's not
a sense whether it's
fiction or documentary.
Say, hey, let's act this out.
This would be really fun.
And presumably the feeding
the baby gets talked about
is another one that was,
talked about it beforehand.
This would be a
good thing to do.
Let's go feed the baby.
I think that's one
of the Lumiere--
I forget if it's
one of the brothers
or one of their other relatives.
But no strict separation at
this point between fiction
and documentary.
That distinction
doesn't really exist,
or presumptions about how
people should be interacting
with the camera necessarily.
Anything else that you
guys noticed or thought
was interesting?
AUDIENCE: Just to build
up-- what was her name?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Sabrina.
AUDIENCE: Well,
Sabrina said, it's
interesting that
most of the scenes
are very kind of
daily life, mundane.
So like you have a camera, the
first thing you want to film
is yourself, your city,
your family, kind of funny
and joke in the garden rather
than feeling like grand things.
And I thought it was very nice.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
what's interesting is
that as the Lumiere
business progressed,
they started doing more
and more grand things,
like coronations and affairs
of state and visits by royalty.
So it became more news-reely.
So the early stuff is exactly
what you're talking about.
And then it kind of evolved into
something a little different.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, and
sometimes it gets talked about
is that royalty and the
wealthy came to see,
this is a really cool invention.
This should really
be focused on us.
And so when the
Lumiere operators would
come, for example,
they'd be like,
well, you should really
do the coronation.
And the operators were
getting like, this
is like the 35th
coronation we've filmed.
So you had this kind of process
where elite members of society
we're like, well, we're really
the appropriate subjects
for this.
But as you're both saying,
that at the very early stuff
is just this kind of daily life.
And so one of the things
that's interesting about this
is that some of the
very earliest films,
what documentary film
folks like to say,
is that some of the very
earliest films that were made
were actually what we might
think of as documentaries,
or actualities as they
refer to them at the time.
And one of the things that's
always really striking to me
is that the sense of wonder.
But like, wow, look at
this new contraption.
Look what it can do.
Look how we can see
the world differently
through using this machine.
And look at how we
can look at ourselves.
And you get this kind of
sense of excitement and fun
about this new way of
looking through the world
through this technology.
And I think that was something
that's very powerful early
on in that and that we--
important to think
about in terms
of these kinds of technologies
and how people related to them.
But now we're going to look
at another kind of camera
that was a very different
kind of invention,
and what were the implications
of this different kind
of invention for what got made.
OK, so at the same time or--
almost exactly the same
time, Thomas Edison
was also working
on moving images.
And he invented the
kinetoscope in 1893.
And in contrast to
the cinematograph,
the kinetoscope weighed
over 1,000 pounds,
it required electricity, and
so it was impossible to move.
Basically it stayed
inside a studio at Edison
in East Orange, New Jersey
called the Black Mariah,
so you have pictures of the--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Which
is on the left there.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Mariah there--
And because this camera was
so big and heavy and unwieldy
and it worked on electricity.
And of course Edison wanted
to work on electricity
because that was his invention.
So it was partly,
again, business concerns
were also central in terms
of how the technology got
formulated or it got used.
So instead of the camera
going out into the world,
it's not something
you can really
do with an invention like this.
So what do you do instead?
You bring things to the camera.
So what do you
bring to the camera?
AUDIENCE: People.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
People doing what?
So if you're inside this kind of
studio, this big, black studio,
and you've got this
camera that sits still
and that runs on electricity--
performers, vaudeville.
So you think about what
was going on in terms
of entertainment at the time--
things like vaudeville, street
performers, circus acts,
often being brought
in front of--
to perform within the studio.
And that being filmed.
And that and that being--
moving it already more in terms
of the entertainment model,
for example, rather
than more what
we would think of as in
the documentary model
with the Lumiere camera.
So just to show you a few
clips of the Edison films--
CHRIS BOEBEL: I just want to--
I want to make one point.
Just in terms of how the
technology that you're using
influences both the outcome,
as Chris has mentioned,
but also the experience.
Just imagine the
difference between being
the person here and that
person, as a filmmaker.
This person is out in the
open, in the sunlight,
finding their subject, children
playing, trains going by,
people walking
around, walls falling.
There's this sense of
freedom and experience
and engagement with the world.
That person is sitting
in a black room.
And people on a tight
schedule are coming to him.
And that is a really
great encapsulation
of a dichotomy that
continues to this day.
This is two different
ways of making films.
And so now should we
look at an Edison?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So the
serpentine dances and then
the strong man was the
one that I had marked.
OK, we can watch another
one just for fun.
OK.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
you want to see more?
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Unless you guys--
you want to see another one?
For fun?
OK.
OK, so comments,
reactions on those?
AUDIENCE: It almost
seemed like as a--
you could only see
each individual frame.
It was almost like you
took like a strobe light
and it was recording
with the strobe
light flashing like that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, the
frame rate is much higher.
That's why it's all a little bit
slow motion if it's played back
at 24 frames a second.
But yeah, it's
artificial light, much
higher frame rate, a much
more constant frame rate.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Do you want to
explain what the frame rate is?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh, so
frames per second,
like how many frames go through
the camera in a given second.
So the standard for video is--
well there are several standards
now-- it's like 24 or 30.
Standard film, old
film technology is 24.
The Lumiere shorts are
not a constant frame rate
because it depends on the
skill of the operator.
If you are cranking at a
very, very smooth rate,
you might get it to be about 18
or 20 or something like that.
Edison, of course, it's
electric, so it's very constant
and I think a higher
frame rate than what
it's being played back at in
these shorts, which is why
it has that slow motion feel.
But yeah, exactly,
it's got probably--
the strobe is the
fact that there's
a shutter on the camera that's
a very even shutter that's
going at a constant rate.
And the light is-- it
took a lot of light
to make these, which is
massive, massive banks of lights
inside the studio, as opposed to
the daylight and the hand crank
and very different feel.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Other reactions?
AUDIENCE: I had very
obvious this comment
that compared to the
other films where
it will come as portable,
instead of having
the camera going after the
people and chasing them,
you have people kind
of trying to stay
within the frame
dictated by the camera.
So the dancer is doing
all these wonderful moves,
but is basically standing
on the same spot.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
it's studio filmmaking,
which again, persists, of
course, to the present day.
But it's completely controlled.
It's in a completely
artificial environment.
And they're told
where to stand, what
to do, start, stop, action,
cut, let's do another take.
I mean, it's very much what
we think of as mainstream,
commercial filmmaking.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And so what
else about content, in addition
to being entertainment,
what kinds of entertainment?
I mean one thing to be thinking
about during this period-- what
was popular entertainment
like in the 1890s?
A lot of it was geared
towards working class men
in urban areas.
So that's partly--
the cockfights,
the fighting matches.
I mean so this was part of
popular culture in urban areas.
Particularly, this
is also the period
where you have massive
industrialization,
so you have a lot of factory
workers who are moving in,
and who have money because
they're earning wages,
where they can have
money to go and pay
to go watch these things.
So it's built into
that entertainment,
popular entertainment for a
growing population of people
who are earning
wages in factories,
for example, and in
this early stuff,
particularly for the men.
And then you also have
the circus stuff as well.
Whereas the Lumiere
stuff, the Lumieres
were coming from a much more
middle class background.
There's so much more middle
class sensibility to--
I mean, you see the factory
workers and the factory
too at the same time, but
a somewhat different kind
of feel in terms of focus,
in terms of content.
So again, thinking
about, well, what's
the social context in which
these things are being made?
As I talked about earlier,
that's one of the things
we always want to
be focusing on,
the social embedding of the kind
of images that are being made.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So let's--
so we'll pause.
Let's take a--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
That's the end of this.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --a tiny break.
And then we can come back.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Well, and just to let
what we're going to do after
this couple minute break,
is show you some of the very
earliest clips from science
documentaries again, which are
I think are quite fun and quite
interesting.
And we'll just talk
about them very briefly.
And then we're just going to go
over the syllabus for the class
and explain more about the
mechanics of how it works.
OK, so just to look at a
couple of the very earliest,
what now gets referred to
as the earliest science
documentaries-- and if
any of you are interested,
I did put a--
I mean obviously
you weren't expected
to do any reading today
before you got the syllabus.
But if you are
interested in this topic,
there's an article for today
by Hannah Landecker that
talks a little bit about
these very early science
documentaries and
why say scientists
thought they were interested.
So if you're interested in
that, it's really short.
It's like seven or eight pages.
So if you're interested,
there's information there
if you'd like to find out more.
OK, so the early 20th
century-- so again,
just a few years
later from the period
that we were talking about.
So say the first 10 years
or so, the next decade,
you also see in addition to
the kind of Lumiere shorts
that you saw, and then
you see the Edison stuff
across the ocean, happening
in the United States,
you also had this other
subgenres starting to emerge.
And one of the very early
subgenres that you start seeing
is an interest in science films
about-- these little films
about science, which are
interesting from a number
of reasons that we're
going to talk about.
And one thing to keep in mind
is if you go back and think
to the 19th century--
now I'm trying to
think of what's
the big Hollywood
movie that was done
about natural history in the--
I'm trying to think of
a Hollywood movie that
might convey some of the
interest in natural history
that was so prevalent in
the late 19th century.
Insects and-- it's
not ringing a bell.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
No, you've seen it.
We saw it together.
So I'm just misremembering the--
not being able to
remember the name.
But if you think back
to the 19th century,
there was a lot of interest in
natural history, for example.
So popular activities, say for
a lot of middle class families,
might be going out and
finding various insects,
and making displays,
and pinning them down,
and doing natural
history drawings of birds
and other kinds of
wildlife, for example.
So there was a lot of
there was a lot of interest
in natural history in
the late 19th century.
And that being part of a broader
popular interest in science
that was quite prevalent
during this time
period, the late 19th century
into the early 20th century.
So there's a lot of popular
interest in science,
and the natural history model
being one strong piece of that.
And so the very
early-- what often
gets referred to as the
very first science film
is a short film
called Cheese Mites.
And it was shown at the Alhambra
Theater in London in 1903.
And it was organized
by a businessman
named Charles Urban.
And it was shown as
part of a program.
It also had other popular
entertainment acts and music
on the stage.
And so we're just going
to show you Cheese Mites.
So Cheese Mites is looking
through a microscope
and filming what you see looking
through a microscope on cheese,
microorganisms on cheese.
OK, so here some of
this very early film
footage of these
microorganisms on cheese.
And then when it was
shown in its theater form,
eventually they added a little
piece at the beginning of it,
where you see a man kind
of dressed in formal
or sitting down
to eat his lunch.
And he's going to have
some Stilton cheese.
And he looks down at
the Stilton cheese.
And then you look through
the eye of a microscope
and you see all these
microorganisms on the cheese.
And he's like aghast at
what's on this cheese.
So the idea of like
to get the audiences
excited about thinking
about these microorganisms--
So any reactions to this?
Any things that you guys
thought was interesting?
When it was shown in theaters,
it would have been played--
music would have been playing
as part of the entertainment.
CHRIS BOEBEL: But the
original version is--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: --is silent.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And that's what--
we saw it in its entirety,
I mean it's just a shot
through a microscope.
AUDIENCE: How long
was the original one?
Was incredibly long?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: That was it.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Yeah, just a couple
of minutes, whatever they
had on a short reel of film.
Yeah, no, I mean, who knows how
long it took them to make it
and how many outtakes there
were, probably a lot, probably
a lot.
I mean, to me it's
interesting because it's
the equivalent of the IMAX
movie, nature film of today,
or the Discovery Channel.
It's about taking the audience
somewhere completely new
and outside of their
experience in the natural world
and revealing something,
something previously unknown.
So it seems relatively crude.
But it's fulfilling
the same function.
And I think
audiences went crazy.
They loved it.
It was a huge hit.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
That was the question
that I was going to ask you.
Why do you think they
would have found--
I mean why would this have
been so interesting in the time
period?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
some things
you can't see to yourself.
But like if you know some other
films like they kind of show
the whole, like we had
to tell the subjects
versus the [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
and actually, so again,
this the kind of excitement
around film technology
during this period,
because it's like, wow.
It's like this whole new
way of seeing the world.
And one of the things that
was really exciting here--
and this was not only exciting
for popular audiences,
it was also exciting
for scientists--
was the fact that you
could see things--
I mean through a microscope,
you could see things
on a really small scale.
But here could see them moving
And what Hannah Landecker
argues in her article
about this is that this was
really exciting for scientists
also at the time, being able
to see things in this way,
because for them, it really
emphasized the power of process
or the fact that things
were always in motion,
they were always moving.
And she talks about
how at the time,
it was talked about, well,
if you had a lot of--
in science textbooks,
you might have
a lot of drawings of biological
organisms, for example.
But they were static drawings.
And even if you had photographs,
the photographs were static.
So you might be
talking about something
like reproduction
of microorganisms
or whatever it might be.
And you might-- obviously you
know that that's a process.
But it doesn't really
hit you over the head
in the same kind of way
as when you see organisms
actually moving all the time.
And so, according to her,
that this was something
that was a real revelation
for science at the time,
about oh, wow, things
are always in motion,
they're always moving.
And so there was a
lot of excitement
about what can we see
through this new technology.
And one of the things
that's interesting
that she talks about,
and a number of others
talk about also, is that
for these very early pieces,
you might have
scientists be excited
about the same kinds of
images that might then later
be shown in theaters.
So the bit that we just
saw, Cheese Mites, you
might have scientists watching
these images at conferences,
thinking about
their implications,
or does it suggest different
kinds of experiments to do,
for example.
And then you put the
bit about the guy
eating his Stilton lunch for
cheese, and being aghast.
And you put music to it and
you show it in the theater.
And it might be the
same exact same images
being shown for popular
audiences, which
is quite interesting.
But to show you a few
more of the early ones
and what people
were interested in--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Do you want to
see with sound or without?
It has that kind of
narration, narrative.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Because we don't
have just the
images without any--
we have all about the
people stuff in between.
Should we do it without sound?
Let's do it without sound.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The problem
is then, it makes--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK,
then do it with the sound.
That's fine.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So this is a
little documentary put together
by New Scientist.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In August, 1903, this
film made its debut
at the Alhambra
Theater in London.
Its stars are cheese
mites crawling
through a piece of Stilton.
But on the big screen, they look
more like eight-legged aliens.
It was an instant hit and
marked the beginning of science
in nature filmmaking.
- The original film
was just a minute long
and it just shows cheese mites
shot down the microscope.
There has been a story
put about that the cheese
manufacturers complained
about the cheese mites film.
- Cheese Mites was produced
by Francis Martin Duncan,
an amateur natural historian
who previously published books
on how to take photos
through microscopes.
Another nature enthusiast
called Percy Smith
followed in his footsteps,
and made a film called
The Birth of a Flower in 1910.
- Percy Smith at the time
was working as a clerk
in the board of education.
And he fixed up a special
filming set up in his bathroom.
He could darken the room.
And he made a [? Jim ?]
crack device made up
of a seesaw with
two old tin cans.
The tin cans sort of
filled up with water.
And when it would reach
the bottom, clunk,
it fired the shutter
of the camera.
And using this extraordinary
homemade piece of apparatus,
Percy Smith made the
very beautiful film,
Birth of a Flower.
- Since film reels were
only one minute long,
filmmakers were limited
to making short films.
But these were shared alongside
other musical variety acts
that were typical at the time.
People went to the theater
simply to be amazed.
And that's just how they
reacted to Smith's next film
of a juggling flying.
- The Acrobatic Fly was
a bit of close-up film,
[INAUDIBLE] shot
through a microscope.
And what Percy did was
to tie the fly down
with a tiny piece
of silk thread,
and then just pass small
objects to the fly.
It looked as though
the fly was juggling.
And that's what the public saw.
But in actual fact, Percy
came to the conclusion,
the fly was just doing
what came naturally to it,
ideally trying to walk.
So when he gave the fly a
little ball made of pith,
for example, then the fly
walked and the ball went round.
And in the best
shot of the film,
there's a ball with
a fly underneath
and another side walking on top.
Spectacular, people loved it.
- It soon became clear that
the public loved nature films.
And the trend was
linked to Britain.
In America--
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK we can--
that's enough.
Reactions, comments?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Who said
science isn't entertaining?
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Reactions, comments?
AUDIENCE: Interesting
ethic of the documentary,
making a tie a fly with a rope.
You don't tell anything
to the audience.
Nobody cares.
Now we wouldn't be able
to do the same, right?
CHRIS BOEBEL: The cockfighting
film, the Thomas Edison-- yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
again, at this period
before this distinction between
fiction and documentary film,
that distinction doesn't really
solidify until around 1930.
Although, certainly there's more
debate about different kinds
of genres before then.
But here, yeah, kind of
a blending of genres,
and again, sort of the science
film and the entertainment
film, and not necessarily
at this point there
being a strong distinction.
I mean, well, certainly the
fly with the little mud balls,
I don't know how many
scientists were watching that.
But with Cheese Mites,
they might be, for example.
So again, not a really
strong distinction.
And the time lapse photography,
that's another one.
I mean back to this
question of, what
would have been
exciting at the time?
How can you see the world
differently or in a new way,
or through new eyes using
this kind of technology?
And this is actually a lot of
what Hannah Landecker focuses
on was that this early use
of time lapse photography,
where you would take a little
bit, maybe every seven minutes.
And through doing that,
you get a new sense
of development of
plants, for example,
because if you're just
watching it with the naked eye,
just observing
with the naked eye,
you're going to fall
asleep before you really
watch much happening.
And it's hard for people
to concentrate and pay
attention for that long.
But if you use time
lapse photography,
you get this appreciation
for like, oh, wow, here's
the process.
Here's the movement.
This is how it goes.
And again, placing more
emphasis on movement and motion
and process, and
getting scientists
excited about thinking about
it in those kinds of terms.
So again, the power
of cinema cameras
to get people thinking about
the world and new kinds of ways,
whether it's through
entertainment,
or whether it's through science
or whatever it might be--
other kinds of
reactions to this stuff?
AUDIENCE: It's still
kind of surprising to me
as far as with the
flies [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, it carries.
It really travels,
right, it carries well.
Yeah, especially the double
shot, with the flies.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
Any other reactions,
thoughts on this?
So what did some of these early
films then bring together?
The popular interest in
science and natural history,
along with the interest in
science, at the same time,
so bringing together both
in the same domain or space.
The interest in
spectacle, so this
is part of what Chris was
talking about earlier, again,
these exciting new ways of
seeing the world associated
with cameras and
what they could do,
and then also just the sense
of spectacle through that.
And popular entertainment
as we talked
about, music acts, vaudeville,
popular entertainment-- so all
of these coming together here.
And again, as
Chris mentioned, we
do see-- it's not completely
foreign that we do see this
again like the big
science IMAX films,
right, where it's about the
spectacle of seeing things
in this way because
they're so huge.
And you want to sort of
feel the power of it.
It's presented to the audiences
that this is about science.
And this is at least somewhat
educational, good for kids.
But it's also very
much entertainment.
And so again, where's the
boundary between entertainment
and science and
spectacle and looking
at the world in new scientific
ways or whatever it might be.
So the point of seeing
these early science
films, and a couple of
things we want to emphasize.
Number one is that the
science films were there
from the very
beginning of cinema.
So science films were
there from the start.
That these films were
always in conversation
with other forms
of entertainment
and popular culture.
So now it might be in
conversation with Hollywood,
for example.
Back then, it was
in conversation
with vaudeville, music
shows, whatever it might be.
But that there was always
some kind of dialogue
back and forth.
And again, this ongoing
both link and tension
between science films as a form
of education and science films
as a form of entertainment.
And where do you
draw a boundary?
Is there a boundary?
Once a boundary starts
to be differentiated,
where's the appropriate
boundary or not?
And that's the end
of my bit on that.
Any further thoughts,
reactions to these early films?
Have guys ever seen any of these
before from this time period?
No?
I don't know.
It's cool.
I think they're cool.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
they're great.
Especially the Lumiere
shorts and the juggling fly.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
Anyway, and you can find,
if you're interested,
you can find more stuff online.
And we also have--
one thing that in
the DV lab office,
we also have the DVDs of
stuff that we're showing
and others that you can borrow.
A lot of them, there's
three copies of things,
if multiple students
want to borrow stuff.
This one we only have one.
But if you're interested in--
you can also sign
them out with Dave
if you're interested
in watching more.
But unless you guys have any
further thoughts, comments
on this, we'll go
right to talking
about the logistics of things
and looking at the syllabus.
And Dave, feel free to
throw in any thoughts
if you think of anything.
OK, what big things?
We already talked about
how the class is divided up
into Wednesday,
Friday, and how, again,
that we've tried to-- we
don't want things to--
there's a lot of material-- but
we don't want things to seem--
we want things to seem
relatively contained
and we don't want it to
be too much for people.
So again, that we
tried very hard to have
the articles that
you're going to read
be quite short and concise.
There's one short paper.
It's quite short.
It's early on.
And the reason why we
did that is because
towards the beginning,
you're going
to be doing less
production work as you just
learn how to do
that use the camera
and learn how to use sound.
And so we do the paper early on.
And then later,
the focus is more
on the visual end of things.
And we do want people
to do a final project.
And the idea, again,
is linking together
to thinking about documentary
filmmaking as a process
and science as a process.
So we want to encourage people
to find some kind of topic
that's broadly related to
science and engineering,
but can be very loose.
Come up with what you will.
But at least that's
somewhat the idea.
And particularly,
because we're at MIT,
there's a wealth
of topics around.
And towards the end, we
can talk a little bit
about some of the topics
that students have made films
on in the past and
ideas that there might
be things to do around campus.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And this should be
a good time, again, to mention
that next Friday, February 11--
do we have enough
to pass this around?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, we've
got-- well, we've got three,
so at least--
if anybody wants--
CHRIS BOEBEL: At the
MIT Museum, there's
going to be a screening of
last year's Dv lab projects.
And I would definitely,
if you are available,
if you can make it,
I would definitely
encourage you to come.
It's a really wide range of
films on many, many topics.
And as Chris said, science
and engineering, very broadly
defined.
So there's a lot of
really interesting stuff.
And it'll give you a sense
of what other people have
done in this class.
Everybody last year came in with
basically no experience at all.
And they produced some really,
really interesting work.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And the
final projects are short.
So they range from say
two minutes to 12 minutes.
So they're not--
we're not expecting
a documentary at the end.
And also what the
students from last--
the class was slightly
bigger than this,
but it was still
relatively small.
I think we had eight students.
And seven students
kind of voluntarily--
they wanted to take another
semester of the class.
And we didn't have
an advanced version
of this class,
which we're trying
to work on for students who want
to keep going further with it.
And so they kind of all did
it as an independent reading
group.
So I mean--
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Right, so actually,
the films that you
would see next week
are more evolved
versions of what
they turned in at the end
of the semester last spring.
They spent another
semester working on them
at a less intensive
level, but they
did do a lot more editing
in some cases more shooting.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: --through
a second semester.
But it was nice to know that
nearly every single student who
took the class was so interested
and excited in the topic
that they chose to take a
whole semester, working on a--
CHRIS BOEBEL: --less
intensive level.
And they did a lot
of really fun work.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And just
mention, since we're on this,
we might as well mention
right now some of the topics
that they did.
One of them, one
student did one,
she wanted to convey how the
repetitive nature of lab work.
So how do you convey the
competitive nature of lab work
without really
boring your audience?
So she kind of cut it in a
really fun, fast, quick way.
But the whole idea is to
convey repetitive tasks
in the laboratory.
And it's like a
two-minute piece.
And it's really fun.
And it's nice to watch.
Totally different topic,
another student ended up doing--
this is technology
very loosely defined--
she ended up doing a piece
about Armenian puppet theater.
She ended up going to
Armenia over the summer.
She got some money to do it.
And she ended up-- she
and a partner of hers
ended up filming this
really beautiful footage
of this puppet
theater in Armenia.
So she came back and
made a piece about that.
We had a Wellesley
student who ended up
doing what it was called an
edible garden at Wellesley.
So it was thinking about
environmental issues
that, so science, that end.
One of the other
graduate students
was following how trash
circulated on campus,
so from outside her dorm door,
to following it into the--
following its way along campus.
I'm not even sure
where she ended it,
because she was
still finishing it
up quickly before the
screening next week.
Tom-- did you want to
describe Tom's about--
CHRIS BOEBEL: So another
grad student in STS
did a film about a controversy
in a materials science lab
over how to interpret images
from atomic force microscopy
instrumentation.
So this is imaging
extremely small,
nanoscale structures,
things that
are so small that actually
the instruments are
doing the interpreting.
And you can't actually take an
actual picture of something.
You're only getting an
interpolated version
of what's there.
And of course, so in that
case, you really you're
interpreting the image, just
like actually in a lot of ways,
watching a film.
So it created this
controversy within this lab,
with different people having
different interpretations,
which actually
turned quite serious.
And he did a film about that.
It was a really
interesting film.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
Max, undergraduate,
did a short piece
that's a portrait
of a graduate student
who works in a lab, who's
also a stand up comic.
So and this was actually--
his earlier project had been--
and I'm actually sorry he didn't
finish the earlier project,
because the earlier the
earlier project was really fun.
This one's fun too.
But the earlier
one was he wanted
to work against images of
science students as geeks.
And so he had this
really funny introduction
where he went around and he
just did random interviews
with people around
Cambridge and in Boston
about what do you think about
scientists and MIT students.
You get all these like
stereotypical stereotypes.
And then he would kind of
went around campus here
and tried to counter
that, but in the very kind
of funny, humorous way.
So that was a fun piece.
So he's got the short
portrait of this scientist
slash stand-up comic that
he's going to be showing.
What else?
I'm spacing out.
Melissa's on West
African cloth--
she actually
originally started out
doing one about the way
Africa was being represented
in discussions about
international development
around campus at MIT.
So that was the original
project she started doing.
And then the second one ended up
being about West African cloth.
So again, you
could think of that
as technology broadly defined.
[? Janai's ?] earlier
piece was on the Fab Lab.
She interviewed a
graduate student
who is working on
prosthetic pieces in India,
but focusing on this
person in their labs,
so kind of a portrait
a person in the lab.
But what else?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Emily,
another grad student,
did a film about livestock
competitions at a state fair.
And it's got a lot of very
interesting kind of look
at competitiveness and
human-animal relationships.
And again, it has a very
science technology and society
approach.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
environmental also--
CHRIS BOEBEL: And environmental
approach to this event.
So anyway, it definitely
are worth checking out.
It might be fun for you
to see what they produced.
But one thing that we should
also say on the other side,
is we fully recognize that
this is a difficult process.
And as I said before, there's
a steep learning curve.
So there's a lot of
resources to help you.
There's the lab, there's
Dave, there's me,
there are office
hours appointments.
We will do our best to help
you through the process.
And it's really absorbing.
Almost everyone gets really
interested in engaged
with what they're doing.
But there are those
disasters that happen.
I mean films don't work
out, either by accident
or just bad luck.
Cameras break, or
footage doesn't turn out.
Or what do you?
But there is a bail.
There is a way to bail.
And that is-- we
strongly discourage it,
but there is-- you can write a
paper about why your film isn't
what you want it to be.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
and this is described--
I believe in the syllabus, we
have a description of this.
So yeah, not to put so
much pressure on this--
I mean particularly,
a lot of what
you're going be doing
early on is just
individual exercises as practice
to get to know how to use
the camera and the equipment.
And then so then this is
largely this final project.
So the idea is, again, because
people, a lot of people
will not be having
any prior experience,
that if the video-- and this is
part of the learning process,
right-- if it doesn't
come out quite the way
that you want it
to be, that's just
part of the learning process.
So what we wanted
to do, so people
don't have to worry
about grades or other--
because again, it's
part of the process.
You don't want to feel bad if it
doesn't come out quite the way
that you wanted it to come out.
So what we wanted--
so what we do is we
give people the option.
Then if you don't like the way
your final project came out,
you can submit it along
with a five-page paper where
you talk about what
you were trying to do,
and why it didn't quite
end up being the way
that you wanted it to do.
And we'll grade you
on and we'll grade you
on that and the amount of
effort you put into it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So it's
not instead of a film,
it's along with the film.
It's kind of get to write a
response to your own film.
If it's not-- if you
feel like uncomfortable
that something
happened and you're
afraid of being graded on it.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
ultimately, the grade
is not-- we're not going
to grade-- because I mean,
this is not the
case in this class,
but it could conceivably
be the case in the class
where somebody has
a lot of experience.
And then you have other
students who have none.
And you can't compare the
outcomes as being the same.
So the focus in terms of
grading for that final project
is largely the amount
of effort that you're
going to put into it.
So again, it's all part
of a learning process.
And we don't expect things to be
perfect coming out at the end.
So don't freak out about that.
And you're going to be graded
on the amount of effort
that you put into to try
and put your piece together.
MAN OFFSCREEN: One thing I
would encourage you guys to do
is to get to know each
other, like exchange numbers
and contact info, because a
lot of these projects, really
helps to have an
extra set of hands.
[INAUDIBLE] same thing.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And I think
we'll actually formalize that.
I mean obviously if people
have concerns about sharing
their email, that's fine.
You can opt out.
But we will I think,
probably even on Friday,
create a mailing list
and have everybody
have everyone else's email
address, because you'll all
be in a situation where
you'll need somebody
to help you do sound or help you
carry the equipment to a taxi
or shoot something.
And those favors get returned.
Again, what happens
with these classes
is that you become a small
community of filmmakers
and you work together.
You end up supporting
each other.
And it's a very important
part of the process.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And those
kinds of things, though,
will be more like the
second half of the class
when you're working on your
final project, where again,
the first half of the class is
more these smaller exercises.
CHRIS BOEBEL: If you
look at the syllabus,
you'll see that really the
last five or six weeks,
it really starts to be all
about the final project.
And a lot of the
reading drops away.
And a lot of the exercises stop.
And you're really
given a lot of time
to develop, conceptualize, and
shoot and edit your project.
And it starts fairly early.
We have a formal process where
you think about your ideas.
You present your ideas.
You develop your ideas.
And then you begin
to create them.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So to
talk a bit about equipment,
and I'm sure Dave is going
to have more to add to this--
so basically what we have,
we have six camera packages.
So we have six
high-def cameras--
or maybe, I don't know maybe
you want to talk about this.
I don't know if I should go on.
We have six tripods.
We've got six sets
of sound equipment.
There's two nice, big Macs
with Final Cut Pro in there.
And again, there's all the
Macintosh editing computers
in the new media center.
So the information on
all that is in there.
So that's the equipment that
we have available for you
guys to use.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Oh, that's right,
two [? flex films ?]
for a bit later.
And so bit by bit, again, we're
not expecting any background
knowledge.
So on Friday, the
first lab is just
going to be the basics of
how you shoot the camera,
I mean just starting
completely at the basics.
This how you set up a tripod.
This is how you work the camera.
The next class will be the very
basics of doing some sound.
So it just starts
out bit by bit.
And we do have
optional readings.
And again, they're
completely optional.
But if anybody's interested, say
if we're doing sound that week,
and you want to know
more about sound,
there's a book that's
a reference book.
It's one of the--
we have a copy of
it in the DV lab,
so you can access it that way.
But I would encourage
you to have a copy of it
so you have it around.
But we'll have recommended
chapters, for example,
from this one, The
Filmmakers Handbook,
that can tell you a little
bit more background on sound.
So you're not meant to
actually read those things.
I mean you're meant to
use them as references.
So use them when you
need to use them.
And there's also a reference
book on an editing.
So just know that you have
those resources there.
And if you are
interested and you
do want to do a little
reading on sound
or whatever it is that
strikes your fancy,
you know where to
go look for it.
But I imagine most students
will probably just use it
as references when you need it.
But it's nice to
have them around.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The editing
book, in particular,
it's a very good book.
It's essentially a software
manual for Final Cut Pro.
And I would strongly
recommend that you buy it
or get access to it in some way.
I mean there's also a
lot of online material.
But a lot of editing is
learning how to edit and think
like an editor.
But there's also a whole
level of software training
that we will spend some time on
here, but honestly not enough,
just because we don't
have enough time to do it.
So you will definitely
want to seek out
other resources for editing.
And again, that includes
Dave, that includes me,
that includes this manual,
or online resources.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And there is
also a copy of that book also.
MAN OFFSCREEN: [INAUDIBLE]
just give a website.
I heard that
[INAUDIBLE] students
get free access to the
online tutorials, lynda.com.
It's L-Y-N-D-A .com.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right,
it's a great--
MAN OFFSCREEN: L-Y-N-D-A .com.
CHRIS BOEBEL: A great
resource, and yeah,
MIT just cut a deal that
allows MIT students to get
free access.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But again, that's
a resource you're
not expected to do.
I mean, this is if you decide
your interest in this stuff
and you're excited
and you want to put
the extra time into doing, it
all those resources are there.
So that's one thing that is
really exciting about being
able to do this class.
And we're very grateful for
the support we've gotten
and doing it, is because
there's a lot of resources
here for a very small
group of people.
So you've got all
this equipment.
And you've got three
people, and just lots
of resources that are able
to take advantage of if you
really--
and people will do this
to different levels.
Some people will just sort of--
some people will get
really excited about
and want to do it more.
And you've got the resources
if you want to do it.
And other people will not have
the time to be able to do that.
And you're not
expected to do that.
But these are just
the resources that you
have in case you want to
take advantage of them.
So that's that.
But other things
about the equipment--
one thing about the hard drives,
also-- you're going to get--
everybody is going to get
a hard drive to put your--
once you start getting
material, you're
going to store it
on this hard drive.
They're really delicate.
And we've had issues
with some of them smoking
and bad things happening
to them, because they're
really not meant to
be-- they're delicate,
they're not really meant
to be carted around.
But on the other hand, you
have to bring them to class.
So just be careful with them.
Like if you have to put
them in your backpack,
wrap them in something.
Or just try to do what you can.
CHRIS BOEBEL: They
will come with a box.
You'll have a box.
But it's a little--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Try to be as
gentle with them as possible
because you don't want
to end up in a situation
where something happens to the
drive and you lose all your--
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
just to be clear,
you'll have the use of
it for the semester.
But you'll have to turn it in
at the end of the semester.
So you'll want to think
about ways of packing up
your project, or at
least the final version,
on a data disk or another
hard drive or whatever.
But you do not have to buy
your own hard drive in order
to be in this class.
We give you a hard drive.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And also
tapes for the cameras--
everybody can get a couple tapes
out when you go to shoot stuff,
you can get a tape.
But if you're using
more than one or two,
you would be expected to
buy the additional tapes,
because we don't have
enough money in the budget
to be able to--
CHRIS BOEBEL: I
mean, again people
shoot anywhere from a couple
of one-hour tapes for a project
to 15.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Depending
what you have time for.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --on
what your ambition is
and what your project is.
So we can't give
unlimited tapes.
But we do have a small number
that we will provide you.
And they're not that expensive.
There are only a few apiece.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And when you
go to sign the equipment out
in DV lab, you'll be signing
out the equipment through Dave.
We do have an insurance
policy on the equipment.
But it's got a really
high deductible.
It's like $1,000 deductible.
So be-- obviously, it
goes without saying,
be really careful
with the equipment.
I mean we are covered, again,
with the insurance policy.
But be as careful as you can.
Don't lend the equipment
to obviously to other--
because it's unclear,
legally, whether we
would be covered if somebody
else who wasn't actively taking
the class was using
the equipment.
Anyway, so just be aware
of that with equipment.
Anything else with
the equipment, Dave?
MAN OFFSCREEN: I think
it makes more sense
to talk about it when
we're actually [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, OK.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
I mean that's just
that broad overview.
One other thing--
Dave and I will both be
setting up our office hours.
And to the extent that we can,
we'll try to listen to you.
And since it's a
small class, we'll
try to set it up at times
that work for as many of you
as we possibly can accommodate.
So there's some flexibility
in our schedules.
If everybody wants us to come in
from 1:30 AM to 3:30 AM Monday,
Wednesday, Friday, that
probably won't happen.
But within or to a
reasonable degree,
we'll try to work with you.
And we'll go through
all that on Friday.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And one
thing, we didn't actually
talk much about the content.
We talked about the
logistical issues.
But in terms of content,
we're starting out
with a bit of a
chronological, we're
continuing a bit
chronologically.
We started with some
of these early films.
We're going to next week look
at some really interesting ones
from the 1920s.
We're going to move up to when
we get to the 1960s, again,
we have a lot of
changing technology.
So you start having
handheld cameras
that also make a
big impact and how
documentary films can be done.
So we're going to go through a
number of different documentary
film trends through the
'60s, through the '80s, '90s.
We're going to
try to have some--
it's less of an
international perspective
than we would like to have if
we had more time in the class.
But we do try to do some
looks internationally.
And we're also going to have a
guest speaker this semester who
does work on documentary
filmmaking in India, who's
going to be coming to speak.
And we have a couple
of classes where
we talk about those issues.
And then later on it kind
goes through chronologically.
So you get a sense
of different schools
of documentary filmmaking.
And part of the idea
with that is then
that you get the idea when you
go to do your own piece, here's
all the different
styles out here.
I can pick and choose
kind of from what
I think is interesting to do.
And then later on, we're
going to focus more
on particular kind of
topics, like say nature films
or say science
fiction, which are just
kind of fun to think
about, and give you
another sense, again,
of different kinds
of documentary film work that's
been done out there related
to science and engineering,
broadly defined.
So any questions
about any of this?
No?
And don't be overwhelmed
by the syllabus.
This came out of a prior class
that didn't have production.
But it was like eight
years of teaching it,
so we've got like, the
syllabus just keeps growing.
But it's got resources on it.
And there's a lot of, again,
additional things on the class
website, just in case
people find them useful.
Things that have come up and--
CHRIS BOEBEL: And we'll
have plenty of time
to talk about some of
the other nuts and bolts
of the class on Friday as well.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, and the lab.
So the lab meets in
here also on Friday.
And again, on Friday, we'll
just be doing the introduction
to the camera.
That's it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Thanks.
Thanks for coming.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Thank
you all for coming.
Looking forward to having you.